É verdade que usar muito álcool em gel
pode fazer mal paraa saúde? Pergunta que
eu recebi aqui. Olha só. Então, vamos
falar aqui sobre um papo sério, sobre
uma coisa que virou rotina na vida de
muita gente, que é o álcool em gel desde
aquela época, a partir de 2020. Sabe
aquele frasco que tá sempre na sua
bolsa, no carro, na mesa de trabalho?
Pois é, ele pode ser um grande aliado,
mas também pode virar um problemão se a
gente não souber utilizar de forma
correta. E o pior é que muita gente nem
imagina o estrago que o excesso pode
causar, principalmente na pele. Então,
deixa eu contar uma história rapidinho.
Outro dia eu atendi uma paciente,
professora, que chegou no consultório
com as mãos parecendo lixa, estavam
rachadas, vermelhas e doloridas. Ela me
falou: "Doutor, eu passo álcool gel umas
30 vezes por dia, eu tô fazendo tudo
certinho para me proteger." E aí que tá
o problema. O excesso de zelo vira um
tiro no pé.
A coitada estava destruindo
completamente o manto hidrolipídico das
mãos, aquela camada de gordura natural
que protege a pele. É como se ela
estivesse tirando o verniz protetor de
um móvel todo santo dia, entendeu? O
álcool 70%, que é o que a gente usa no
gel, é um solvente poderoso. Ele mata
vírus, bactérias, fungos. Isso é ótimo
em várias circunstâncias, mas ele também
pode dissolver os lipídios naturais da
nossa pele, aquelas gorduras do bem que
formam a barreira de proteção. Imagina
só, nossa pele arquitetura complexa, tem
ceramidas, ácidos grassos, colesterol,
tudo isso forma uma barreira inteligente
que mantém a hidratação dentro e os
invasores pro lado de fora. Então,
quando você passar álcool demais, é como
se estivesse usando um detergente
industrial nas mãos várias vezes ao dia.
E tem mais, nossa pele não é estére, ela
tem um microbioma, um ecossistema de
microrganismos do bem que vivem ali em
harmonia. São bilhões de bactérias,
fungos e até vírus que formam o nosso
exército de defesa natural. Quando você
usa álcool gel em excesso, você não mata
só os bichinhos ruins, você dizima
também essa população benéfica. É como
jogar uma bomba atômica no jardim para
matar uma formiga, entendeu? O resultado
é uma pele desprotegida, vulnerável,
propensa a infecções, alergias e
dermatites. Agora, presta atenção nesse
dado que é muito importante.
Pesquisadores da UFPR descobriram que
álcool gel de má qualidade ou fora do
padrão pode até virar um proliferador de
bactérias. Isso mesmo que você ouviu o
contrário. Se o produto não tiver o 70%
de álcool certo ou se tiver uma
formulação ruim, ele vira um ambiente
propício para crescimento bacteriano. É
tipo você achar que tá se protegendo,
mas na verdade tá criando um clubinho de
germes na sua mão. O tiro sai pela
culatra. E olha que interessante, quando
a barreira da pele fica comprometida,
não é só a proteção contra germes que
vai pro espaço. A gente também prejudica
a produção de vitamina D na pele. Sim,
nossa pele é uma fábrica de vitamina D
quando exposta ao sol. E a vitamina é
fundamental pro nosso sistema
imunológico. Ela regula a célula de
defesa, ajuda na produção de peptídeos
antimicrobianos naturais. Então, quando
você destrói a integridade da pele com
álcool em excesso, você tá sabotando o
seu próprio sistema de defesa de várias
formas ao mesmo tempo. Os profissionais
de saúde, professores, caixas de
supermercado, essa galera que precisa
higienizar as mãos o tempo todo, são os
que mais sofrem. E as crianças idosas,
então, a pele deles é naturalmente mais
fina, mais sensível. caso de crianças
com dematites severas, porque os pais,
na maior das intenções, passavam álcool
gel a cada cinco minutos com medo da
criança pegar algo. É compreensível o
medo, mas o excesso causa mais mal do
que bem. Bem, mas calma, não precisa
jogar o seu álcool gel no lixo. A
questão aqui é equilíbrio, é bom senso.
Sabe qual é a recomendação dos
especialistas? Use álcool gel quando
você não tiver acesso à água e sabão.
Isso mesmo. Lavar as mãos com água e
sabonete ainda é o padrão ouro. O
sabonete é menos agressivo, remove
sujeiras que o álcool não consegue tirar
e não resseca tanto a pele. O álcool gel
é para quando você tá na rua, no
transporte público, naquelas situações
em que não dá para lavar as mãos, não
tem acesso à água corrente. E quando
usar o álcool em gel, existe um jeito
certo, uma quantidade do tamanho de uma
moeda. Espalhe bem por toda a superfície
das mãos entre os dedos e deixe secar
naturalmente. Não precise esfregar feito
louco, nem passar de novo e de novo. Uma
aplicação bem feita já resolve. Agora,
se você tá já tá sofrendo com
ressecamento, tem solução. Primeiro,
procure álcool gel que tem hidratantes
na fórmula. Alguns vêm com glicerina,
extrato de aloe vera, vitamina E.
Segundo, hidrate as mãos sempre que
puder. Passe um creme hidratante bom
depois que o álcool secar completamente.
Terceiro, a noite antes de dormir,
capricha na hidratação, passa um creme
mais gorduroso com ceramidas, ureia,
manteiga de karitê. É o momento da pele
se recuperar do estresse do dia. Tem
produtos no mercado que são formulados
especialmente para reparar a barreira
cutânea. Procure cremes com ingredientes
prebióticos e pós-bióticos. Eles ajudam
a restaurar o microbioma da pele. É como
se você estivesse replantando o jardim
de bactérias boas que o álcool destruiu.
E olha que bacana, alguns hidratantes
modernos tm fosforilucolina, que cria um
efeito de luva protetora que resiste até
a lavagem das mãos. Outro pronto
crucial, cuidado com álcool gel
falsificado ou de procedência duvidosa.
Na pandemia, teve gente fazendo álcool
gel caseiro, vendendo um produto
adulterado. Além de não proteger, pode
causar queimaduras, alergias graves.
Então, sempre compre de marcas
confiáveis, veja se tem registro de
Anvisa, confira se tem mesmo 70% de
álcool na composição. E tem mais um
perigo que pouca gente fala, o álcool
gel é inflamável. Eu já vi casos de
pessoas que passaram álcool nas mãos e
foram acender o fogão. Resultado,
queimadura séria. Desde o início da
pandemia, a Sociedade Brasileira de
Queimaduras registrou mais de 100 casos
graves que precisaram de internação.
Então, depois de passar o álcool, espere
secar completamente antes de chegar
perto de fogo, de isqueiro, de
churrasqueira. Tome cuidado. Para quem
tem pele sensível com tendência a
eczema, dermatite atópica, o cuidado tem
que ser redobrado. Nesses casos, o ideal
é conversar com o dermatologista que
para ver se dá para fazer um álcool gel
personalizado com uma concentração menor
de álcool ou com mais agentes
hidratantes. Tem farmácia e manipulação
que fazem isso. Então, se informe,
pesquise. Sabe o que mais me preocupa?
Essa cultura do quanto mais melhor que a
gente criou.
Não é assim que funciona, pessoal. Nosso
corpo tem mecanismos de defesa naturais
incríveis. A pele íntegra, o microbiôme
equilibrado, o sistema imunológico
funcionando bem. Quando a gente exagera
no álcool gel, a gente tá sabotando
esses mecanismos. É como tomar
antibiótico toda vez que espirra. Você
não tá se protegendo, tá se
enfraquecendo. E olha, vou compartilhar
uma dica de ouro aqui. Fortaleça o seu
sistema imunológico de dentro para fora.
Mantenha bons níveis de vitamina D de
dado. Tome um solzinho todos os dias.
Tenta tomar uns 15 a 20 minutinhos, já
ajudam muito. Consuma vitamina C,
vitamina A, zinco, selênio. Tudo isso
fortalece as suas defesas naturais.
Alimentação colorida, variada, frutas,
verduras, proteínas de qualidade, numa
bem, controle o estresse, faça
exercício, tudo isso é importante, é
proteção de verdade que vem de dentro
para fora. Então, resumindo a ópera,
álcool gel importante, pode ser sim, com
moderação inteligência. Priorize lavar
as mãos com água e sabão. Sempre que
possível, use álcool gel quando não for
possível acesso à água corrente, quando
necessário, não por paranoia. Hidrate
suas mãos religiosamente. Cuide do seu
microbioma cutâneo. Fortaleça o sistema
imunológico. E lembre-se, nossa pele é
um órgão vivo, complexo, que precisa de
cuidado e respeito. Não é só uma capa
protetora, é parte fundamental do nosso
sistema de defesa. A mensagem que eu
quero deixar para vocês é: sejam
espertos e não paranóicos. Usem a
ciência a favor de vocês e não contra. O
álcool gel foi uma ferramenta
importante, continua sendo útil, mas
como tudo na vida, o segredo estar na
parcsimônia e no equilíbrio. Cuide da
sua pele como você cuida de qualquer
outro órgão do seu corpo, com carinho,
atenção e bom senso. Sua saúde agradece
e suas mãos também. Yeah.